chef vieux team je ne gagnais pas d'eau
ou même en travaillant 15 heures par
jour je faisais des fois j'en fais des
beurs et chasser la mouche à la que peux
tu m'appelles grand vent
on assortit d'une et violent les bassins
de l'arbre et
quand je sortais cinq minutes prendre
l'air le reconnais sur mon salaire
j'allais je venais je pourrais de mon
mieux entre lui et la mouche à laeken où
elle grand
violon
sur son tracteur en plein mois d'août je
crois qu'ils accélèrent comme un fou
qu'est-ce qui volait à ses cheveux
c'était la mouche al akhbar
2 le ray
il fonce tout droit sur la niche du
chien et basterds hurlant dans le ravin
on l'a retrouvé mort sous les essieux
victimes de l'âme xala que flo
tél
bon on l'a
katainen
le jour où on l'a enterré
personne n'est venu sauf le curé
quelqu'un qui se plie en deux
grand
de là à pleurer
pas même
jack